student here in Mumbai and my question
is uh why women are not accepted into
mos in
India sister asked a very good question
that why are women not accepted in the
mosque in India so India has to blame
not the Quran and Hadith I told in my
lecture do not judge Islam by looking at
what the Muslims do or what the Muslim
Society does Judge Islam according to
the Quran and
the our beloved Prophet said there a
inkari the prophet said do not prevent
the female Servants of Allah from going
to the
mosque another Inari volume number one
in the book of Salah just a few Hadi
before that he said that if the female
servants that means the Muslim women
Servants of Allah if they want to go to
the mosque at night do not prevent them
now it is the Indian culture now when we
allow a woman to go in the mosque we see
to it that she gets equal but separate
facilities separate entrance separate
place of ablution Wu separate place of
prayer we don't believe in intermingling
like when you go to the church or when
you go to the temple why because in our
Salah sister when we pray we believe in
equality of human beings We Stand
shoulder Tosh shoulder irrespective
whether the man next to me he's black or
white yellow or brown king or popper I
stand close to him shoulder to shoulder
now if a lady is there close to me
shoulder to shoulder the medical doctors
tell me the temperature of the lady is
1° higher if I pray standing with her
shoulder to shoulder I will confident
more on her than Allah subhana tala
therefore separate but equal facility
separate entrance separate place of wo
you have to wash yourself wash your legs
you can't do in front of the namam so in
India most of the Moss don't have but
alhamdulillah it has started and know
several mosque in Bombay where they have
facilities for ladies we have several
mosque in South India where I've been
today but I do agree with you it is very
Less in percentage if you go to Saudi
Arabia almost all the mosque more than
95% of the Mosk they have facility for
women more than 95 but it's 99 99.9 I
don't know more than 95% of the m has
separate facility for ladies you go to
London you go to USA most of the for it
is India so the problem is with the
Indian Muslims therefore in my talk I
say that see to it there should be a
separate facility for the
women separate but equal F so that they
too can pray to almighty God in the M
hope the answer the question sister
thank you you're most
welcome yes brother good evening sir my
name is Ashish and my question is there
is concept in Islam by paying money to
the victim's family by paying money to
victim's family
from accused family and getting released
from the crime what is the concept
behind that and is it not Injustice with
the victim's
family brother as the question that what
is the concept of theam mean paying
blood money in Islam that if someone has
murdered someone or killed someone
whatever reason the family member of the
person who's murdered can
excuse can excuse by piing the money
this concept is that if someone driving
a
car or maybe by mistake while walking
something happens or by accident someone
dies here if it is out of
negligence yet for example doctor is
doing surgery and this proven out of
negligence the patient has died Islamic
law death
penalty but there the relative of the
person who has died fine we agree the
Nia was good he didn't actually kill my
son I forgive him but
negligence if it is done while trying to
save a life he goes C free but if
negligence he does
something and the person
dies then death penalty because his
fault in this
case if it's proven it is 100%
negligence then the family members may
say even if negligence I forgive him
okay I forgive him like free I forgive
him by taking one rupee or by the 1
million rupees maybe that 1 million rupe
may be a penalty okay don't do it again
now you have done it I don't want to
take your life I forgive you 1 million
rupees a penalty so this concept in
Islam that the person who has died his
family members can forgive by asking a
penalty if it is a conspiracy
and a murder 100% proven then it is
death penalty these cases are mainly
when we know that the person has a
chance to be forgiven if someone goes
and does a Bomb Blast on the street and
kills 100 people innocent people no
forgiving death penalty direct you
understand now for example while if
you're doing something maybe a building
is being constructed fine and the
negligence the worker gets electrocuted
it's the fault of the Builder now the
family members say okay I don't mind
forgiving you know my husband used to
give me every day 2,000 Rupees now if I
demand 500,000 Rupees even his full life
how much could he give me 25,000 a year
5 lakh would take how many
years how many 20 years so now if I take
that 5 lakh rupees I can invest it
somewhere and get 4,000 rupees 5,000
rupes a month correct so fine I forgive
him and with this money at least I can
survive the various aspects that angle
this is not the only aspect I'm giving
you examples so in this way what happens
at least in Indian law finish death
penalty does the government take care of
him the earning member has died the wife
and children on the
street does the government help no so
here at least as a compensation now they
invest the money every month they get
5,000 rupees so at least some part of
their life is taken care of it may not
compensate
completely and sometimes the person may
just forgive without taking money
also so therefore the are various
situation Islam has permitted so that
it's beneficial for both hope that
answer the question yes brother and
kindly have your questions on wom's
rights the topic of the day
please Shalom I'm Danny uh I'm a student
I read Bible studying more about the
biblical manners understanding and I do
read uh Muslim
books uh now I'm not relating to all the
question what Bible and Quran has uh
this is something related to my friend
who is my best friend his name is don't
want to take it sorry now he is married
and due to some reason uh he's uh
planning to divorce his wife and I find
it out that that was a very small reason
that he want to divorce his
wife and secondly yesterday I was just
reading this Mumbai miror at midday that
112 years old guy Muhammad from somal he
getting married or sorry get got married
to this 13-year-old girl
safia and I was very disturbed to answer
my friend because I just asked one of my
friend and he told this is what we learn
and this is what we return and this is
what we follow so I just went on to the
internet as is that this is the easiest
way I see because I don't get a chance
like Zakir brother for you to question
it so just I'll just read it for you if
you give me a chance to read it from
what I founded from the internet
regarding this uh justification and the
relationship which Muhammad had is that
a true or you just help me how to come
out of this issue and I can go to my
friend and say that this is what exactly
the Quran
teaches do you want to read or do you
want me to answer I'll just read it
first for you but you un satisfied with
the answer now uh whatever you may say
hope I answer the question not give you
the answer no what the paper says forget
about it okay if you satisfied with the
answer what you have in your hand then
that's sufficient if you're not
satisfied I'll give you the answer
directly uh just let me read it okay
okay take care brother put it in just
five sentences in precise form otherwise
don't read it I'll do I'll do that for
you sir uh this is actually let me just
quote it from sah bukari Volume 7 book
number 62 which uh zabir Bin Abdullah
says uh when he got married uh Haz
Muhammad says what type of lady have you
married he replied I'm married to a
metan he said
Muhammad why don't you have a liking for
a virgins and for fondling them zabir
also said Haz Muhammad said why don't
you marry a young girl so that you might
play with her and she with
you now it's a I was like little bit
disturbed this is the preference of Haz
Muhammad or after reading bukari volume
number five he says interested in
reading the Hadith other than the
question you posed Hallelujah correct
now I just you ask me a question I give
you the answer you want to read the
answer of somebody else because you want
to qu the quot directly because I get an
answer from you so that's if you have 2
plus 2 I don't know the answer I want to
tell what other people said why you
bother I'll give you the answer directly
it is four what other people said 7 8 10
forget about it and that's why I came
over here sir that's the reason why you
reading somebody else's answer if you're
not satisfied okay correct yeah that
means I'll have to comment on both on
the question as well as the answer
correct okay I'll do both no problem see
what is the ni is important if your Nia
was to get the answer why Muhammad 112
years old 113 years old old married 13
years old the answer I've given you but
you also wanted the answer of prophet
Muhammad correct yes because directly
what do you have to say I'm not
satisfied with the answer given on the
internet given on the paper directly ask
the question on the Hadith rather than
beating around the bush I'll give both
the answers okay I'll give the answers
hope I may satisfied with your answers
too inshallah insh that depends upon you
if I said 2 plus equal to four you said
no it is five I can't help it I'll I'll
take it what you say but I believe what
I can believe it sure sure you have to
believe what you believe you can't
believe what I believe until you believe
what I believe true sir because it's not
law of contradiction sorry please go
ahead sorry what did you say please go
ahead because I want to know the answer
from you as far as Prophet Muhammad
peace be upon Him is concerned fine I'll
come to it later on regarding the man by
the name of Muhammad you said no yeah
because it's some person from African
Somalia from Somalia 112 years old you
said yeah married a girl of 13 years old
yes sir and it's a fifth marriage fifth
marriage fifth marriage yes not five
together maybe one married and divorced
I said
the at any given time you can't have
more than four now coming to the answer
why in
Islam you can marry a woman the moment
she gets matured if she reaches puberty
you can marry that is Islam fine a woman
to marry for a man the moment reaches
puberty till he
dies he can marry anyone choices
is would you marry a woman 15 years
older to you no no your choice but the
prophet Muhammad married his choice okay
Prophet Muhammad at the age of 25
married a woman K with her who was 40
years
old you will not marry I will not tell
you you have to marry it's your
choice now he wanted to marry a woman 15
years or older to her because she was
Pious who are we to object
he's willing and the woman is
willing because wait wait let me answer
please don't interrupt you POS the
question I said sorry sir yes I accept
it no
problem so the husband and wife who are
we to object that woman wants to cover a
head you said don't cover the head why
she wants to cover ahead and the
president of France said women should
not cover that why he wants to enjoy
seeing woman you can go on the Miami
Beach why does he want to do it in
France does that make sense subjugating
that woman doesn't feel subjugated he's
feeling subjugated why he's feeling
subjugated because he cannot enjoy women
he cannot enjoy the lust so the problem
is in him not in the woman covering the
head but the man is 112 years old
Medical Science tells us even a man of
112 years can
procreate can give birth to a child true
yes sir yes I'm a medical doctor no he
wants to marry a 1ye old girl who has
reached puberty what is your problem you
don't give your daughter to him who no
don't give am I telling you am I telling
your sister to marry him no no if the
parents also agreed and the girl agreed
she may be liking that man 112 years
what a Pious man reminds me of the
sahaba I sacrifice everything because
the Beloved Prophet Muhammad sallallahu
Al wasallam said that if you marry a
spouse you look for four things virtue
nobility wealth and Beauty the best
among this is virtue and if a woman of
13 years old finds a virtuous man of 112
years I would prefer if I know he's
virtuous if I know not any can Harry I
would not mind giving my daughter if I
know that he's a virtuous man and will
see to it that he takes my daughter to
Jenna I would not mind but after
verifying he's such a virtuous man
remind me of the sa the caliber of Omar
abak Ali Allah be pleased with them
all why not but today we see more for
beauty more for wealth I'm not saying
that the man of Somalia was virtuous I
don't know I don't know but can it be
possible yes chances are less can it be
possible yes chances are less why not if
the girl is willing therefore I said in
my my talk the marriage can only
solemnize if if the man and woman agree
that does not mean tomorrow a man Even
though 50 years come and ask my daughter
I will not give if I said he's as
virtuous as as the I cannot find a
better match I cannot find I cannot find
a better match what you have to realize
that maybe that girl found that man to
be virtuous maybe I don't know I haven't
interviewed her I haven't interviewed
him maybe that man found that girl
virtuous I don't know so if the man and
the woman agreeing who are you and me to
interfere why are we trying to interfere
their rights now you may have married a
girl I don't know good or bad you may
think she's beautiful someone may think
she's
ugly and someone says why have you
married her sorry I'm not getting
personal your wife may be beautiful
masallah but someone comes and objects
why have you married ugly woman you will
say what is bothering you I find it to
be beautiful who are you to interfere
will you get angry or not will you get
angry or not Beauty subjective someone
comes and tells you oh brother whatever
your name
is you know your wife is so ugly you
said you mind your own business that's
my wife why are you interfering if
somebody comes and criticize is your
wife that is your
choice so as far as that 112 year Somali
man is concerned and the 13e girl is
concerned chances is very negligible 0
1% but if both agree who are we to
interfere coming to the answer of
prophet M wasallam that why don't you
marry a younger woman virgin woman the
prophet may be knowing how that sah is
there's a person who came and said that
while I'm fasting can I kiss my wife the
prophet said yes you can another sahaba
comes can I kiss my wife the prophet
said no so the sa said first one you
said yes said second one we said no why
because he knew that the first man could
control his desires while fasting even
after kissing the wife he will not go
beyond that the second person once he
kisses his wife he will break his fast
he will go beyond that Prophet knew you
don't know I don't know similarly the
prophet may be knowing that if he
marries a matr maybe yet he will go
after Bey the prophet advises him but
what did the prophet do the first woman
he married was 15 years older to him 15
years with you wouldn't like doing you
just told me that correct yes so the
prophet he knows because he found py in
KH Allah be pleased with her therefore
she's one of the four P women in the
world so the prophet knows like I being
a doctor I may give one medicine to one
person second person second medicine you
ask why am I changing medicine because
I'm a doctor I know you not a doctor so
the prophet gives different advice to
different people depending upon the
situation you don't know but Prophet
knows and do you think what the prophet
said is wrong is Right some people may
like younger girl some people may like
older girl so what do you have to
realize that it is nothing wrong it is
advice given by the prophet did he say
something which is wrong no perfectly
right but see his lifestyle all the
women he married except for one only one
was virgin all of them they were either
divorcees or they were
widowed uh sir actually it's not liking
or liking getting married to you ask me
the question I give the reply I'm asking
the question someone objects but how
does Quran relate to this people simple
question which people this people those
who are getting married in this
particular they're liking or not liking
they like something says do not inherit
woman against a wishes Surah n 4: 19 but
if the woman wants and the man wants who
are you and I to
prevent who are you and I to prevent
what is bothering you I'm asking the
question
if he finds pety in that young lady and
that young lady finds piety in that
elderly man what is bothering you and me
tell me that is it UNM medical
no can they procreate yes what's the
problem imagine someone comes and tells
you why have you married a black woman
why have you married a white woman I
mean that's your choice in Islam a woman
becoming black or white does not make a
superior inferior what the prophet said
the best is virtue now why did the man
of Somalia
at the age of 112 married 13 I don't
know I'm Le bothered to know is it
logical yes chances are very less
possible same thing what the prophet
advis so I'm asking you the question if
the girl and the boy are agreeing why
are you interfering with the choice is
my question do you have a right to
interfere is my question I'm asking your
a question do you have a right to
interfere when the husband and wife are
doing something which they like it's not
going against the Quran it is not even
juping your rights sir my answer yes sir
again is their liking or not liking I'm
not interfering in them they may like
112 years of old old man or 13 years but
my thing is how this Quran words related
to this people like they are doing it
what they doing it did you hear my
answer the reason for criteria to get
married is you should reach puberty have
they reach puberty or not can a
13-year-old girl reach puberty yes or no
do you know the answer no can she reach
puberty uh 13
years you don't know you doctor sir
please tell me in India yes sir in Delhi
the report came if a girl reaches
puberty by the age of 10 nothing to be
worried about age of 10 also it's very
common many girls hundreds of girls who
are less than 39 they reach puberty many
it's not common so once you reach
puberty finish you may have preference
okay the Indian law says 18 years Indian
law Indian law if he was an Indian it
would have been illegal according to the
Indian law America say 16 years who's
right America or India I'm asking you
the question 16 years or 18 years who is
Right according to their
law ah
law is according to the quranic law very
good answer this is very good answer the
problem is that when America says 16 you
have no problem
when Quran says 13 what is your problem
I didn't say no problem you can no
problem thank you then you got the
answer Quran says as long as they agree
there is no problem in Texas in
Texas the American law says a woman
should be minimum 16 years old in India
if a 16y old girl gets married illegal
Haram prohibited in Texas because the
Texans they marry at early age there's a
special law for women of Texas
at the age of 14 they can get
married now what's the answer do you
agree with a woman of 14 years in Texas
to get married right or wrong again I
said sir it's the their law their law
correct who are you to object I I'm
asking a question in America if a 115
year old man marries a 14y old girl is
it allowed or not in Texas allowed so
when Texas
allows so why can't the Quran allow it
may not go down on your throat no
problem you don't marry I don't know
whether you live till 11 12 years old on
I no I don't want to be but even if you
live let God wish if you don't want to
marry it's your choice it is the choice
of an individual this is the right word
Islam has given which you want to take
away from man and woman Islam has given
that right they have the right to choose
Brother May the peace of Jesus Christ be
with you sir
brother as far as if you say may Jesus
Christ be with me I follow the teachings
of Jesus Christ peace be upon him you
say shalam alum it's a verse of the
Bible from the Gospel of Luke chapter
number 24 shalom shalom it is shalam
alum it's not Shalom peace be with you
sir it is shalam alum it's not Shalom
the same it is shalam shalam alum means
it's not only Shalom I'm giving you the
reference Bible Gospel of Luke chapter
number 24 verse number 36 it is
shum shum shalam alum in Hebrew in
arabicum May peace be on you yes brother
but when you said that may Jesus be with
me in what in teachings or in what as
far as teachings are concerned Jesus
Christ peace be upon him said in the
Gospel of John chapter number 16 verse
number 12-4 I have many things to say
unto you but he cannot bear them now for
even the spirit of truth shall come he
shall guide you un all Truth for he
shall glorify me he shall tell you
things to come Prophet Jesus peace be
upon him said there is another Messenger
to come and his name will be Muhammad
peace be upon him so I'm following the
teachings of Jesus Christ peace be upon
him that the reason I'm following the
teachings of prophet Muhammad peace be
upon him if you don't want to follow the
teachings of Jesus Christ peace be upon
him it is your problem you can refer to
my video casset similarities between
Islam and Christianity you'll get more
information for any question you can go
behind the queue and ask me brother
please go behind the que and you can ask
me brother yes
sister hi my name is Meredith and I'm a
student studying Psychology from Canada
uh my question is very simple uh how can
you say that men and women that there's
no sex ISM when the very setup of this
conference is sexist for example the men
are seated can repeat the question
slowly sister yes why is it that the men
are seated in front of the women um the
very structure of this conference is
sexist why is
that M sister asked a very good question
that why aren't the women seated in
front no why are we not if you're going
to separate us how come we're not left
to the right why is one in front of
question that why are the wom if you
believe in equal why not left and right
why not it's a very good question sister
because the Quran says in Sur chap
number 24 vers number 30 say to the
believing man that he should lower his
gaze and guard his modesty whenever a
man looks at a woman any Breen thought
comes in his mind he should lower his
gaze now if the woman are sitting on my
right I will only have to speak looking
on the
left you know because I can look at them
yeah I can look at everyone this I
cannot see your face also from here you
may look at my direction if you if you
want to see me Clos you can see on the
screen there no problem but for me the
Quran says the moment I look at a woman
I should lower my gaze unless she's my
wife or she's my mother she's my
daughter and if someone says that
someone looks at a woman and nothing
happens to him then he requires a
psychiatrist so if you were here I'll
talk to you like that so you'll tell me
what an manner is this you know showing
me his
back now my gaze is there knowing the
microphone I cannot see you I can just
see okay just little bit here and there
so I'm maintaining my hijab now when we
have lady speaker speaking only ladies
front row no problem so what happens
because it's a gen
speaking there are occasions some
occasions then we have to keep a
partition and we can do that and we have
done that but there such a vast
Gathering so many cameras it will
obstruct so that the reason but in no
way are we trying to say that the woman
are inferior that's the reason you have
going screen close to you mashallah
especially for sisters are sitting a bit
more behind so you can get the view but
in front it will be difficult for me to
speak for me to maintain my hijab for me
to look because in public speaking you
know we are taught you have to look at
the audience if the audience is a woman
in front of me you know I remember once
I'd gone to the gulf
country and I was called for a talk and
a ladies
organization I always said at least the
front row should be gent you know but
they didn't do it so half the talk I
gave looking at the ground and balance
half looking at the ceiling down ceiling
up believe me I was in
hell not because I was in company of
ladies I was in hell because half my
lecture I gave looking at the ground and
half my lecture looking in the ceiling I
had to maintain my hijab here I can I
can talk to the person I can look at him
I can stare at him if he's sleeping I
stare at him you stop sleeping you
know in public
speaking but with the ladies the it is
for maintaining the hijab so that's the
reason sister it is not at all in any
way trying to belittle them and the
reason we have given you one microphone
instead of two because we feel that the
proportion is approximately 1/3 2/3
that's the reason but the moment last
time when there were more ladies we gave
equal proportion hope that answer the
question sister thank you